>> Female presenter: Welcome to Authors@Google.
Long one of our most acute
and insightful novelists, Russell Banks often
examines
the interesting boundaries between our intention
and our
actions. With his uncompromising and morally
complex new
novel, Lost Memory of Skin, the two time Pulitzer
Prize
finalist is at the peak of his powers. Russell
Banks is
a prolific writer of fiction. His many books
include
Continental Drift, Cloudsplitter, The Darling
and the short story
collection, The Angel on the Roof. The Sweet
Hereafter and Affliction
have been adapted into feature films. Banks
has won
numerous awards and prizes for his work. Among
them the
Guggenheim Fellowship, National Endowment
for
the Arts Creative Writing Fellowship and the
literature award from the
American Academy of Arts and Letters. He's
the founding
president of Cities of Refuge, North American
and the past
president of the International Parliament
of Writers.
Please join me in welcoming Russell Banks
today.
[applause]
>> Russell Banks: Thanks, Shannon. It's a
pleasure and of
interest to me to be here and speak with you
guys. It's
not what I would call a regular stop on a
book tour [audience chuckles]
talking to Google and talk to employees at
Google. I'm
happy to do it. It's kind of a nice break
from the usual
routine where I'm sitting in a studio or TV
studio or
at a bookstore doing a program. And so, this
is kind of nice.
Last week I was in Good Morning Miami television,
CBS,
television studio. In the green room with
me, going on
just before me, were two of the cheer leaders
for the
Miami Marlins. [laughter] Silver Lame bathing
suits, bikinis along with Billy the
Marlin the mascot. This is going to be a hard
act to follow. I'm glad they aren't here today.
[laughter]
And actually,it was a hard act to follow.
The woman whose show it was interviewed them
briefly.
And then, they actually had a routine where
they did a cheer.
And then, she said, "And now, for something
different." [laughter] Mr.
Banks has written a novel about convicted
sex offenders moving
under a causeway. And since she brightened
it, "And it's
right here in Miami." [laughter] The local
pride kind of overcame
her horror on the subject matter. And then,
I had my
three or five minutes of interview while she
read a
teleprompter and I tried to answer questions
in that short space, which is
impossible. But that is a more likely venue
for someone
like me who's on a book tour for a novel than
this. This
is a more welcoming one I think. But I guess
it would be
most useful to you. And that's really what
I wanted to
do is be of use to you. Is really talk about
the book a
little bit and read some passages from the
book. And
then, really just turn it back over to you
for questions
and run about till -- what do you say, Shannon?
Till what
time? Quarter of 11 or thereabouts.
>>Female presenter: That'd be great.
>>Russell: Somewhere in there.
Okay. The woman whose show Good Morning, Miami
-- was
right it is set in Miami. Although it's not
called
Miami. It's called Calusa. And also involves
the
Everglades and they're not called the Everglades.
They're called the Great Pensacola Swamp.
And I think, even though anyone who knows
anything about south Florida and Miami recognizes
immediately
the setting, I didn't want to call it Miami
for a number
of reasons or give it its real names for a
number of
reasons not just to protect the innocent but
really so
that I would be free to have events and incidents
and
even locales occur in the story that don't
occur in
reality that I wouldn't be bound by the geography
and the
history and the demographics and so forth
of the city and
of the region. That I would be free to leave
things out
put things in shape it around the needs of
story telling
because it's a novel first and foremost. It's
a story.
And I wanted the traditions and the conventions
and the
discipline and rigor that story telling brings
with it to
determine what went into the story rather
than the place
itself. The way investigative journalists
might do it or
sociologists or documentarian or someone else,
a non-fiction writer would use the material.
And the material is real, too, in a sense
or, I should say, based
in reality as well. The material that is the
context for
the story. And I spend 6 months a year in
Miami and the
other 6 upstate in New York, in the Adirondacks.
So you can imagine which
six months I spend in Miami. [laughter] And
I have an apartment
down there in Miami Beach that looks out over
Biscayne Bay ; it's over on the bay side.
It looks over towards the Miami skyline and
mainland.
And from that, I can see this Julia Tuttel
Causeway which
Barrier Islands to Miami beach. And about
four years ago
articles started appearing in Miami Herald
and a couple
other papers about a colony of convicted sex
offenders
who had served their time in prison and were
now living
underneath that causeway in a kind of encampment,
a shantytown they had built there and they
had been dropped off there with
the connivance and cooperation of law enforcement
officials and parole officers and so forth
because of a
regulation which had been passed in Miami
Dade count that
forbade any convicted sex offender from living
within
2500 feet of anywhere where there were children
are likely
to have gathered which means schools or playgrounds
or
day care centers or anything of the sort.
And so, there
was no place therefore for them to live anywhere
in the
city. And so, they had gathered down there,
sort of like
trolls under a bridge and outcasts. And it
was -- and I
could see it from my terrace -- a terrace
in my
apartment. I could look out and see, this
sort of like a magnet in a
way. Wow, what must that be like. Talk about
the
unintended consequences of good intentions.
You end up
with this situation and you've got, you know,
psychopathic serial rapists and pedophiles
alongside some poor
old guy who got busted for urinating in a
parking lot at 3 in the morning
in the morning. He got drunk and got busted
for indecent exposure, that's a sexual crime.
Or you
got some 21-year-old kid who had sex with
his high school girlfriend who is under 18
and that's statutory rape and that's sexual
crime. And
they're all just thrown together. We make
these
distinctions between first, second, third
degree sex
offenses when we prosecute and convict and
sentence a sex offender,
but after that, they're all lumped together
and they're
all on the national sex offender registry
online. You
can click right straight to it. They're there
permanently.
Their face will pop up, location where they
live, where
they work etcetera will pop right up when
you click right
onto any neighborhood in America you want
to go to.
Thanks to Google, you can --. [laughter] Any
neighborhood
you want and click on a house or a block as
the kid does
here. I'll read a little episode where that
takes place. And they're all wearing electronic
anklets so
they're under permanent surveillance with
a GPS unit attached to make sure they
don't go within 2500 feet of where children
are gathered and don't leave the county in
terms of their parole as well. So anyhow,
this is a growing
population of these people that little cluster
of them in
Miami seem to represent a growing social phenomenon.
And
that reflected a whole lot of other aspects
of our
society as I began to dig into it. And, because
I
started doing a lot. I knew nothing about
this world
really at all. So I began to investigate
different aspects of it. Of just the nature
of the
crime, for one thing, the psychology of what
may be driving some of these
crimes and the circumstances that may have
led to some of
these crimes. These particular range of crimes.
And
also the legal history regarding these sex
offenders.
And also the psychology of the rest of us.
You know,
those of us who shape the laws and regulations
and so
forth with regard to sex crimes. The fears
that drive us
to try to protect our children as it were.
Feel that
they are protected in some secure way. I was
interested
in finding out as much as I could about that.
And much
of this led me to the Internet. And Internet
addiction
among young males particularly and then -- and
that
connection of that to pornography and pornography
addiction as well. And how the line between
fantasy and
reality especially as regards our erotic life,
our sex
lives, sexual behavior and so forth. That
line has
gradually become erased and replaced by a
zone more than
a line. And so, that more and more it becomes
difficult
to know when you pass out of fantasy into
reality or vice
versa. You drift back into fantasy. And increasingly
so
many of us are living in that gray zone between
the two
that our human contact especially our perhaps
our erotic contact with
each other takes place there, in a digitalized
format
rather than through our skin. And thus the
title: Lost the Memory of Skin. And there
are many forms in which we've lost the memory
of skin our basic form of
connection between each other -- basic form
of intimacy
is through our skin and how that's being displaced
and
challenged. Perhaps you people working here
know more of that than most
of the people in the country. But the rest
of us are, nonetheless,
participating in it. It's part of our ongoing
condition,
our ongoing lives. So anyhow, the book kind
of arose out of all
that. Out of that massive material that I
accumulated
without really intending deliberately to write
a novel,
emerged a character of a kid. And it was called
"the Kid"
in the novel. He wasn't given -- we never
know his "real"
name, whatever that is. Everybody has a handle
anyhow online and
elsewhere and this story. The convicted sex
offenders
tend to use pseudonyms. Real names, they don't
want to circulate because you can go online
get their real name and find out they're a
convicted sex
offender. You don't want to rent them an apartment
or give them a
job and so forth. You can't discriminate based
on the
race or sexual orientation or any other socially
identifiable
category. But you can discriminate on the
basis of
people being a convicted sex offender in terms
of housing or employment. Anyhow,
the Kid emerges from the material for me.>>
And when I had
the Kid and I had his inner life starting
to emerge in my
imagination, I knew I could begin to write
a novel about
the experience of this young guy -- 22-year-old
guy -- as
a kind of lost person in many ways like a
lot of kids.
Feral child, as I think of him, who raised
himself, essential. Single parent kid, we
used to call latch key kids. Mother was at
work all day, then is home briefly then is
.
out at night. His only friend
turns out to be his only connection -- thing
he could
love -- person he could love -- is an iguana
which he raises, to a monstrous four foot
long.
I don't know if anybody here has ever spent
any time with
iguanas. You have?
>> Female #1: Well, in my classroom when I
was in some grade school, we had an iguana.
We
all had to take turns taking care of it. That
was a long time ago. But it was an experience.
>> Russell: [chuckles] They're actually quite
unthreatening beasts and
passive and sweet. And they're actually fairly
intelligent. They
do engage human beings pretty easily. They're
vegetarians. But
they look monstrous. They strike fear into
the hearts of people when they see them. Anyhow.
The
iguana. That's the iguana on the cover. That's
the kid's pet. Iggy is his name; named after
Iggy
Pop. Naturally who I found out later is named
Iggy Pop
because his first band was The Iguanas. [chuckles]
So it came back full
circle back to real iguana. Anyhow, let me
read to you a
little bit to give you some sense of the novel.
Deal with
any questions that you want to ask. I'm just
going to
start right at the front for a little bit
and then jump.
The thing about a novel reading from a novel
trying to
give you a sense about the novel if it's a
good novel, and
one always hopes it is, the pieces of it have
been
integrated and meshed one hopes in such a
way that it's
very hard to excerpt. I also write short stories.
I
love reading short stories aloud because there's
a
beginning, middle and end. Good, that's it;
it's done now. You either get it or you don't
get it. You
like it or don't like it, but you've got the
whole thing. You can't do it with a
novel and I don't like to spend a lot of time
explaining
and I'm sure you don't like to hear a whole
lot of
digressive explaining of various characters
who show up.
I'm just going to read the first few pages
and then jump
to a section that gives you an idea of the
world that the
kid is living in down there. And then, I'll
jump to a
passage toward the end which gives you some
overview
really of the kid's community. This is how
it begins
[reading] It isn't like the kid is locally
famous for
doing a good or a bad thing. And even if people
knew his
real name, it wouldn't change how they treated
him unless
they looked it up online which is not something
he wants
to encourage. He, himself, like most of the
men living underneath
the causeway is legally prohibited from going
online. But
nonetheless, one afternoon biking back from
work at the Mirador he strolls into the branch
library on Regis Road
like he has every legal right to be there.
The Kid isn't
sure how to get this done. He's never been
inside a
library before. The librarian is a fizzy lady.
Ginger-
colored hair around her head like a bug light,
pink lipstick, freckles --. wearing a floral
print blouse and khaki
slacks. She's a few inches taller than the
Kid, a small
person above the waist but wide in the hips
like she'd be
hard to tip over. The sign on the counter
in front of
her says Reference Librarian Gloria, something.
The Kid
is too nervous to register her last name.
She smiles
without showing her teeth and asks if she
can help him.
"Yeah, I mean, I guess so. I don't know actually.
What
are you looking for? You're like the reference
lady,
right? Right. Do you need to look up something
in
particular?" The air-conditioning is cranked
and the place
feels about ten degrees cooler now than it
did when the Kid came
through the door and he suddenly realizes
he's shivering. He thinks at first it's the
air-conditioning.
But the Kid's not cold, he's scared. He's
pretty sure he
shouldn't be inside a public library even
though he can't
remember there being any rules specifically
against entering one as long as he's not loitering
and it's not a school library and
there's no playground or school nearby. At
least none
that he's aware of. You can never be sure
though.
Playgrounds and schools are pretty much lurking
everywhere.
And children and teenagers probably come in
here all the
time this late in the day to pretend they're
doing
homework or just to hang out. He looks around
the large
fluorescent lit room scans the long rows of
floor-to-ceiling, book-lined shelves. It's
like a huge supermarket with nothing on the
shelves but
books. It smells like paper and glue. A little
moldy
and damp. Except for a geeky looking black
guy with
glasses and a huge Adam's apple and big wind-catching
ears sitting at a table with
half a dozen thick books and no pictures open
in front of him like he's trying to look up
his ancestors, there's
no other customers in the library. A customer
-- that's
what he is. He's not here to ask this lady
for a job or
looking to rent an apartment from her and
he's not pan
handling her and he's for sure not going to
hit on her.
She's way too old, probably forty or fifty,
at least and pretty low on the hotness scale.
No,
the kid is a legitimate legal customer who
strolled into the
library to get some information because libraries
are
where the information is. So why is he shaking
and his
arms all covered with goose bumps like he's
standing naked
standing in a meat locker? It's not just because
he's
never been inside a library before, even when
he was in high school and it was sort of required.
He's shivering
because he's afraid of the answer to the question
that
drove him here even though he already knows
it. "Listen,
can I ask you something? It's kind of personal
I guess."
"Of course," well, see I live out on the north
end and
the people in the neighborhood, my neighbors,
they're all like telling
me there might be like a convicted sex offender
living
there. In the neighborhood. And they tell
me you can just
go online to this site that tells you where
he's living
and all and they ask me if I'd check it out
for them.
For the neighborhood. Is it true? Is what
true? You
know, that you can just like go online and
it will tell
you where the sex offender lives even if you
don't know
his name or anything? Well, let's go see she
says like
he asked her what's the capital of Vermont
and leads
the Kid across the room to a long table where
six computers
are lined upside by side and no one's using
them. She
sits down in front of one and does a quick
Google search. See, I'm name dropping there.
[laughter]
Placement -- product placement.
>> Male #1: When I saw that, I thought it
was a bit search.
>> Russell: [reading] She sits down in front
of one -- the computers -- and
does a quick Google search under "convicted
sex
offenders." and up pops the National Sex Offender
Registry which links straight to www.familywatchdog.us.
The Kid stands in a forward tilt behind her
shifting his
weight from one foot to the other. He thinks
he should run now, get out of here fast
before she clicks again, but something he
can't resist,
something he knows is coming that is both
scary and
familiar keeps him staring over the librarian's
shoulder at the screen the same way he used
to get held
to the screen when cruising pornography sites.
The
librarian clicks "find offenders," and then
off the menu hits
"by location." And another menu jumps up and
asks for the
address. You're from Colusa, right? What's
your neighborhood's
ZIP code? "it's 33135." Any particular street
you
want to look up? He gives her the name of
the street
where his mother lives and he used to live
and she types
it in and hits "search." A pale green map
of his street
and the surrounding twenty or so blocks appears
on the screen.
Small red, green, and orange squares are scattered
across
the neighborhood like bits of confetti. Any
particular
block? The Kid reaches to the screen and touches
the map on the
block where he lived his entire life before
he enlisted
in the army and where he lived again after
he was discharged. A red piece of
confetti covers his mother's bungalow and
the backyard where he pitched
his tent and built Iggy the iguana's outdoor
cage. The librarian clicks on to the
tiny square. And suddenly the Kid is looking
at his mug
shot. His forlorn bewildered face. And he
feels all
over again the shame and the humiliation of
the night he
was booked. There was his full name -- first,
last, and
middle -- date of birth, height, weight, his
race, color
of his eyes and hair, and the details of his
crime and conviction. Slowly the librarian
turns in her
chair and looks up at the Kid's real face.
Then back at
the computerized version. That's you, isn't
it? I got
to go he whispers. I got to leave. He backs
away from
the woman who appears both stunned and saddened,
but not
at all afraid, which surprises him. And for
a few
seconds, he considers trying to explain how
his face and
description and criminal record got there
on the computer
screen. But there's no way he can explain
it to someone
like her, a normal person, a lady reference
librarian who
helps people look up the whereabouts and crimes
of people
like him. "Wait, don't leave," I got to go.
I'm sorry.
No kidding. I'm really sorry. Don't be sorry.
No, I'm
probably not even supposed to be here, he
says, in the
library, I mean. He turns and walks stiff
legged away.
And then as he nears the door he breaks into
a run and
the Kid doesn't stop running until he's back
up on his
bike heading for the Causeway.
So that's how it begins.
I'll jump to a couple pages later under the
Causeway.
"While he waits for the blue butane flame
of his camp stove to heat his
supper, the kid stands beside his tent in
the damp
semi-darkness beneath the Claiborne causeway
and contemplates
the smooth blue waters of the wide Colusa
Bay, and the southern outflow of the thousand
mile long Atlantic
intercoastal water way. Bumper to bumper cars
trucks buss
and intermittent motorcycles rumble over him
crossing
between the mainland and the Barrier islands,
on the eastern side of the Bay. It's the
end of a long late summer day. Everyone's
headed home.
Everyone's home is in one place or the other.
The
mainland or the islands. There or over there.
Definitely not here. Not here on the broad,
flat,
concrete peninsula that anchors the rusting
steel piers that
hold up the Causeway. He pretends that he
is alone down here.
He turns away from the polyurethane lean-tos
and tents and the salvage plywood huts nearby
and the men
who live in them standing around like bored
ghosts. And
he gazes out at the Bay thinking not of where
he is but
where he would like to be. This is how he
has learned to
endure being where he is. He peers out at
the bay. He
tracks charter fishing boats and a few large
white yachts
and dozens of small private fishing and pleasure
boats
returning from open waters after a long day's
pleasure at
sea and, in some cases, work. He would like
to be aboard
one of those boats, a pleasure boat or charter
fishing
boat or shrimper. Any one of them would do.
That one or
that one. Or that 50-foot cabin cruiser shaped
like an
arrow. The flotilla passes through Kidds Cut
from the open sea into Calusa Bay
and plows steadily northward keeping down
town Calusa portside and the great Barrier
isles
off to starboard. Individual boats peel off
and make
their way to the thousands of marinas, dock
yards, piers, and
slips, scattered along the mainland and islands
and canals that filigree
both the mainland side of the bay and the
barriers where the fleet finally disintegrates.
The kid
listens to the rumble and roar overhead of
day's end
traffic crossing the Clayborn Causeway and
trying to hear
his thoughts he turns and looks south at the
clustered
skyscrapers of downtown Calusa. 50 story towers
of smoked glass and
gleaming sheets of aluminum and steel high-rise
hotels
Marriotts and Hyatts and Holiday Inns built
for business travelers. They're a
domed convention centers and international
banks and
insurance company office buildings and whole
colonies of
condominiums stacked on top of one another
like gigantic
poker chips. A condo downtown would be fine,
he thinks.
He doesn't need to live on the Barriers. Even
a small
studio with a low floor without a view would
do. He'd
furnish it simply for one person alone with
a single bed
and a table and two chairs and a lamp or two
and a
dresser. Maybe a few small pictures, some
dishes and
pots and pans. Sheets and blankets and towels.
Keep it
simple. Keep it neat and clean. He doesn't
really
require a view, but it would be nice to have
one. To
stroll to the fridge and take out a frosty
Corona and
crack it open and flop in his Lazy Boy recliner
and check out
the city below. At this time of day he'd watch
the glass and metal towers cast their long
shadows over the cluttered port where cranes
and gigantic elevators load and off load rows
of room
sized steel shipping containers from wheezing
freighters, heading to and from China, India,
and
Brazil. He considered three of the creamy
cruise ships line up like floating amusement
parks
beside the docks and warehouses sleepily waiting
to be
restocked with food and liquor and refilled
with fresh island
hopping, limbo dancing tourists from the north.
If the
Kid were a deck hand, he'd have his own bunk
at one of
those ships. He'd have access to a galley
where the cook
prepares meals and the crew eats them. A recreation
room
for watching TV and movies on DVD. He'd be
able to
travel to Asia or South America or to the
islands in the
Caribbean. Out were the sprawling city dwindles
and finally ends
beyond where the malls and bungalows and gated
communities of the suburbs turn into trailer
parks and the
trailer parks eventually merge with palmetto
scrub and cane fields and mangrove marsh
out beyond the great Pensacola swamp, a flattened
red sun
glimmers near the low, unbroken horizon. Streaked
with tangerine strips of cloud the
western sky turns turquoise and then orange
all over and
finally scarlet. The Kid can see that evening
sky from
here beneath the Causeway, but only if he
walks out to
the end of the concrete peninsula and stands
at the
water's lapping edge and looks up. A pair
of 747s depart
simultaneously from the international airport
west of
downtown. Parallel white contrails scratch
the darkening sky.
Then directly overhead one plane slowly veers
northeast in a lone
arc toward England while the other bisects
the dark sky above the black and green gulf
stream on the line that follows the tropic
of cancer
straight east all the way to north Africa
and beyond. He
gazes along the smaller great barrier islands
and the canals between them and the
bayside back sides of the palatial homes of
singers,
professional athletes and movie stars and
the men and
women who import and export drugs and manage
and
launder other people's ill-gotten and sometimes
inherited
money and hedge-funds and offshore accounts
in the Caymans, Turks and Caicos and Bahamas.
Along the canals the mostly Moorish-styled
estates hide flood-lit manicured gardens,
terraces and
Olympic-sized pools behind ten-foot walls
alarmed and topped with razor wire. Looking
east
beyond them he can see the tall seaside hotels,
their
pastel walls splashed with warm light. Neon
signs chum
the names of the hotels against the purple
eastern sky
and blot out the stars. Conquistador. Casa
Calusa. Monteview. Mirador. The cars, buses
and trucks on the Causeway
and bridges and the north/south interstate
and the
traffic jam turnpikes to the suburbs have
switched their
headlights on. And the high-rises and skyscrapers
downtown, fluorescent night-lights ignite
floor after floor as the cleaners,
janitors and watchmen begin their night's
work and from
the rooftops and pent houses, slender beacons
reach like
lone pale arms into the darkness. An offshore
breeze
puts a sudden chill in the air. Night has
fallen in the
city down here wide loud Causeway that connects
the two. [ends reading]
>> Russell: Then a paragraph towards the end
I'll read to you. I
guess it's the summation of the situation.
[reading]
"He's charging up the battery here in this
scene of his
anklet, electronic anklet that he wears. It
takes half an hour to fully
charge his monitor battery. And during that
half an
hour, the kid feels intimately connected to
the millions
of other convicted sex offenders young and
old and in between. Gray genitals on a bus,
public
masturbators, voyeurs, and escalator gropers.
Impulsive
seducers of teen-aged boys, coaches who couldn't
keep their hands off
their athletes. Men who talked dirty in Internet
chat rooms to people they thought were teenage
girls and then arranged to meet them for sex.
Fathers and
uncles who drunkly reached out for their teenaged
daughters as they passed by the sofa. Porn
addicts and fantasists. Lost in the
misty zone between reality and imagery no
longer able to
tell the difference. All of whom at this moment
had plugged
their electronic shackles into outlets and
are sitting in
the bedrooms, living rooms and basements of
houses, apartments and mobile homes. And
garages and homeless shelters; public parks,
in airports
and train stations in waiting rooms offices
and the back
rooms of fast food restaurants. And under
Causeways and
overpasses. As if they were all trembling
leaves on the
branches large and small of a vast electrical
tree that
casts its shadow across the entire country.
[ends reading]
Of course at that point, I'll turn it over
to you. If you have any questions you want
me to
entertain, I'd be delighted. Yes
>> Male #2: Is the anklet locked on to the
person's leg so it
can't be moved?
>> Russell: Right. And you have to keep the
battery charged.
Because you're monitored, you know. Thanks
to Google
technology. [laughter] And you're basically
you break
parole if you don't keep yourself monitored.
You could
be sent back to jail
>>Male #2: Can it be stipulated beyond parole?
>> Russell: You mean the anklet?
>>Male #2: Yeah?
>> Russell: There are places where legislators
are
trying to make it a life time form of surveillance,
yes. And no -- I mean there are challenges,
you
know, to the constitutional rights of people
regarding the sentencing of sex offenders.
In all
parts of the country. It's an easy political
platform to run on in this country. And -- because
everybody's afraid of sex offenders in ways
that are
almost taboo to think about -- to examine.
Just
kind of blanket way. And, you know, without
making
any distinctions or discriminations or getting
up
close enough to understand the differences
--
different types of sex offense, different
conditions
that lead someone into it, and different degrees
of
disturbance that bring someone to it, and
we decided
lumping this whole population together once
they're
out of jail. You know, I've done some talk
shows
while I'm doing this tour. Call-ins, radio
call-in shows,
and some people -- they haven't read the book
--
that's necessarily the first question I ask
when
they come in swinging like that. They call
in, and they say
"You're just justifying the offender, the
perp and
blaming the victim." I said, well, have you
read
the novel?" And they say, "No, and I'm not
going to
either. I think these people should be executed."
They really mean it. They're not kidding.
There's
no discussion of course with anyone like that.
Brings anger and agenda. And they usually
identify
themselves as a victim of sexual crime. And
what
can you say to that? All I can say, "Well,
it's a
novel, and it doesn't blame the victim in
any case.
And you really have to kind of read the novel
to see
that and understand that." But then I've walked
into kind of a defensive position that I don't
want
to be in. But there's a movement afoot all
across
the country to basically make it a life sentence.
>>Male #2: How do other countries deal with
this?
Other cultures?
>> Russell: As far as I know, there's nothing
like the
American panic over sex offender. In Europe,
Canada -- just this morning I spent an hour
on the
radio talking to CBC journalist talking about
it.
She was comparing Canadian approach to American
approach which is far less punitive and makes
much sharper distinctions and doesn't have
this ongoing after. She was sort of shocked.
"Is
it really true you can go online and you can
go to
your own block and your own neighborhood and
locate any
convicted sex offender who may have been convicted
ten
or 20 years ago." Yeah, it's there. Just do
it; try it. It's really
amazing and she couldn't believe it.
>>Male #3: I think just a follow up. I think
in
Italy, they punish the sex offenders by reelecting
them. [laughter]
>> Russell: Yeah, to higher office.
>>Male #3: I want to ask what your writing
process is
like. How do you go about crafting a significant
novel?
>> Russell: Well, umm -- it varies somewhat
of course
from book to book. In this case, when I was
describing how I kind of accumulated mass
of
material that without a real intention at
the time,
at first anyhow, to write a novel about it
I didn't
know what I was going to do with it. I was
just
trying to satisfy my own curiosity and try
to
understand a phenomenon that I couldn't look
away
from any longer and so on. And then the Kid
emerged -- the character -- I began to imagine
the
kid like that. Not based on anybody. It was
easy
for me to imagine a kid going into that circumstance
getting locked into a kind of shadowy world
on the
edge of sex offending because of pornography
and
addiction to pornography and losing track
of his own sex
life. I mean, the Kid's a virgin. He's a convicted
sex offender who was a
virgin, that was a first thing I wanted to
say But in terms of the actual process from
what's
there. I tend to work with two outlines. One
is
kind of an arc of a whole story and that is
very
rough, very approximate. It's sort of as if
I'm
saying, "Okay. I want to climb that mountain
and I
know it's east of here." That's about all
I know.
[chuckles]
Between here and there, I've got to go up
and down,
through the valleys and through the forests
and
foothills and so on to get there. But I'm
not sure
where the trail is going to lead to get there.
I
can see in the distance the peak at least.
And that
large outline governs that direction. It's
like a
compass really. And then, I tend to make a
short
outline that only covers the next ten, 15
pages --
next scene sequence is the way I think of
them. I
tend to write in scenes. Visual -- episodes
that
you can visualize the way you could with that
scene
with the Kid in the library. That's a scene.
And I
tend to write chapters that seem to have evolved
over the years into three or four. Someone
can do
an analysis on it better than I. Three, four
scenes. And that's a fairly detailed outline.
Where I sort of know which
scene follows what. After the library, I want
him
to get back on his bike back on the Causeway
that's
where we meet Iggy the iguana and one or two
of the other guys living under the Causeway
Take it to that.
And the scene where the night is falling.
So that
will give us the physical surround of the
place.
The city that surrounds it and the bay and
all the rest of it. The socioeconomic part
too. So I can lay that out and then
work with that. And be open at the same time
to
developments that may come in along the way.
I
might discover a character as indeed I did
when I
wrote when he goes back under the Causeway
from the
library this character shows up who's a shyster,
a
really scary. Called the shyster because he
had
been a lawyer and a state legislator who was
arrested for pedophilia and soliciting sex
from little
girls in a sting operation. But I just brought
him
in because I thought, "You know, I've got
this kid
who -- yeah, he broke the law but we already
kind of
sense it wasn't a big deal. He's not a pedophile.
He's not a rapist. It's something else he
did wrong. We don't know what it is but it's
not a big deal. But
there are guys down there who are serious
criminals
or psychopaths or sociopathic. So I needed
one. So
I brought him in. Suddenly he's there. This
guy is
really scary. Now he's there. I don't want
to let
go of him. I want to keep him as kind of a
weight
on things, develop the story in ways that
make him a
part of it, too. He's going to have someone
in there
that's really evil. And so, he plays that
role. It
goes like that. Then I have it, affecting
the rest of it. One or two more?
Yeah, another question
>>Male #4: [inaudible]
>>Russell: I can walk over from my place.
Yeah, and I walk over and spend a little time
there.
Not a lot. I wasn't doing any investigative
journalistic
approach to it. I was doing it as a novelist.
What
I wanted were the physical details of it.
I wanted
to know what does it smell like and what does
the
sound of the 24 hour rumbling cars overhead.
What
is it like to be under metal and concrete.
Right
there on the edge of the water -- the bay
-- tide
going up and down. You know, trash coming
up out of
the bay. Flotsam and jetsam, garbage and whatnot.
People throwing stuff off the Causeway as
they
drive. Beer cans bouncing down. Stuff like
that.
I mean, I wanted to see the physical details.
And I
talked to some of these guys who were not
adverse to
talking about their situation. Of course,
many of
them would especially plead their story and
how innocent they are. What raw
deal they got. This that and the other thing.
I
worked in prison before. I know how that goes.
Nobody's guilty when you start talking to
people.
But they weren't threatened by my being there.
They
all felt as though they were being treated
very
badly. I mean, one guy just kept repeating,
"Don't
forget, we're not animals. We're not animals."
That was a cry. And I think he was speaking
for a
lot of them. Yes?
>>Male #5: How do you make decisions about
how many
words you kind of dedicate to describing say
a city
or, you know, describing like a person's physical
attributes. And how do you decide how much
per
chapter per book you want to like dedicate
to those
types of descriptions?
>>Russell: That's an interesting question.
I can't
say I can quantify it ahead of time in any
way. [chuckles] But I do know I
use enough words -- I like phrasing it that,
it's an interesting question. I like enough
words so I can visualize or hear what's being
said.
If you're just talking about exposition, right?
Just descriptive language there.
>>Male #5: So that excerpt was a lot about
the city.
Russell: A Yeah, surround. The world that
surrounds
him. And I wanted to see it as a writer, you
know?
Visualize it. And so, I use enough so that
I could
see it. I mean, I'm already familiar with
it. I
see it every night there where the sun goes
down.
But I wanted to really almost like mentally
photograph it for myself or film it as it
were. And
I mean, Joseph Conrad, the great novelist
wrote,
"Above all else, I want my reader to see."
And he
meant not "understand," but literally see.
Visualize it. I feel similarly. I want myself
to see first of all.
Because in a sense what I'm doing here in
fiction is I'm
creating visual and oral hallucinations. You
are
seeing things that don't exist really
and you're hearing voices that are from another
place. It's out of the body travel really.
When
you're reading fiction if it's any good at
all, you
forget where you are. You go into that world
and
you start having visual and aural hallucinations.
I
mean, dialogue is just that. People are talking.
There's no one in the room but you're hearing
voices, if it's
any good, if it's good dialogue. And so, that's
what I want to induce in
myself as a writer when I am writing. And
then keep
on revising in that direction. And, if it
works for
me, then it will work for a reader as well,
I hope. I trust
that either both yourself and/or the reader
will.
Okay. Well I think it used up the time. One
more
question, sure.
>> Male #6: Do you have someone who worked
to make it more compact, to
change word order?
>> Russell: A I have a very good editor I've
had for a
number of books already. And then, before
him
similarly ten years. My editors either die
or
retire [laughter] All of them -- I've had
four editors over
the years that I work closely with -- and
they all
work pretty much the same way. I write pretty
cleanly myself. I go through the whole manuscript
at the end. We sit down at the table and they'll
have a mark here and a mark there and turn
the page.
Sometimes it will be a whole sentence "What
did you
mean here? It seems kind of vague." Just poking
poking poking. And saying -- you know, forcing
me
to look at it in a way I might not have otherwise
have
question myself. But no real heavy-handed
editing . I never really had that. My first
editor
was a great editor named Ted. Boy was he wonderful.
Great literary editor. And Ted used to do
that and
go through it. You know, have the pages. Spend
a
whole couple of days at my house or in our
offices.
And, but every decision, every crossing, he
would say,
"Don't forget, this is your book, not mine.
And you're
only going to have -- you're maybe going to
have ten
or fifteen books in your lifetime." I'm going
to have
ten or fifteen books that I edit every year
or more. So this is
not my book; this is yours. So the responsibility
also passed over to me. I said, "Wow, this
is
right. I'm not going to have another one for
another three years. Better try to get it
as well done
as I can.
>>Male #6: Do you give him a electronic copy?
>>Russell: Yes, I do. Everything is done -- we
don't
ship any paper anymore. And I work on the
computer.
I write longhand still the first draft, because
I
grew up writing in longhand and then working
on a
mechanical typewriter. Getting a electrical
typewriter is a big deal. I still have my
little Olympus portable or mechanical that
I carried around with me in my teens and
twenties. And so, it sits like a monument
in my office. [chuckles]
I couldn't use it today.
>>Male #7: How much do you do that sort of
editing
before you present the manuscript to the
editor?
>>Russell: Quite a lot. I get it pretty refined
down. I go through dozens and dozens of drafts.
Of
course, working, you know, on the computer,
you can
revise endlessly and there are paragraphs
-- places
in there where I have revised, it seems, endlessly.
Go through
rapidly. But I turn the manuscript in, I'm
pretty
convinced it's done. Except for a little bit
of
this fine tuning that I mentioned earlier.
Yeah.
Okay, guys, thank you all very much.
[applause]